[Music]
welcome to hella opinions your home for
all black everything I'm Sylvia o bell
and joining us today our media
personality ray holiday TV host 7ek
Williams and business coach Jovian Zayn
and content creator Rhonda Holden
okay so today's drink is I want to make
wine to you in honor of the biggest
trending topic this week but more on
that in the bit let's cheer so a good
show okay so let's get right into it
first of all Tory heart has come to the
defense of her ex-husband Kevin Hart
saying she does not believe the comedian
is homophobic and that he was just quote
making a joke trans actress in DM more
tweeted and LGBTQ people tearfully
suffer from homophobia spawned by the
kinds of these kinds of jokes what were
your initial thoughts about that whole
it was like the longest day of my life
it was today that started with the
tweets being uncovered I think even
BuzzFeed was one of the first people to
put that out and then in the middle of
the day it's like he woke up and decided
he was gonna double down like hey I said
what I said it was years ago I'm moving
on I'm not apologizing and then the day
ended with him apologizing right and
stepping down but it seemed like he'd do
one of the other and he decided to do
both and then I woke up to MLK quote it
was alive it was alive
but what warehouse we got their actual
apology at the end of the day I was mad
that I lives my whole day and not only
did it come at the end but you don't
have the job so it's like okay yeah I'll
tell you this the only thing I thought
the entire time was Kevin this is your
moment like this is your moment that
could matter what do you want to try and
do to transcend this little tiny moment
into making it something that could be a
uniting force if you're talking about
don't be negative be positive okay live
it out live it up like all he had to say
was you know what y'all I'm so glad that
Kevin Hart of 2011 or 2010 you didn't
get this opportunity in the Kevin Hart
of 2018 great because now I know this
I've evolved in this way and here's why
I'm excited to take the opportunity to
host the Academy Awards to do this it
just seemed so apparent to me that this
is your time truly to walk it like you
talking Kevin like there's more for you
to do super truthful just real final
point we get permission slip for people
to be a little bit homophobic in a way
that we would not let people be a little
bit racist
[Applause]
nor a little bit colorist right right if
someone said something disrespectful to
our darker huge sisters they would spend
the rest of their life apologizing right
dream but all of a sudden we want to
make an exception causes homophobia we
have a permissive space in our community
to allow and tolerate your every correct
that correct okay so moving to another
bad apology one of us s alleged
mistresses had folks have [ __ ] out
watch this
you know a lot of girls will just deal
with this situation and just be like yo
like I took cardi B's [ __ ] I'm the
reason that they're getting a divorce or
anything like I feel ashamed you know
like growing up it's a lot
I had to take a sip clear my screen so
get off my screen okay so real Mike
Jones seven tweeted oh he was your
husband husband what do you mean I
didn't know how serious your marriage
was like how that even sound okay first
of all slumber bunny or whatever her
name was
I think in in real life once I heard
that she was like and I just didn't even
understand how serious the marriage was
what it was safe enough for them to get
married this period right unless you
would maybe say I just want to tell cry
to be first of all don't talk I mean
then she said I want to talk hard to be
you know I'm a genuine person I'm like a
genuine does yeah you know you're the
opposite of ginger right and I don't you
don't you know right period whatever you
gonna cheat where's that gonna get you
Jovian your wife I am amongst other
things I in the spirit of a wife as the
bug boy that's what I liked about what
you know whenever I get to walk in the
okay what was your reaction I was trying
to think what cardi especially was
thinking when she saw this across her
screen like I just couldn't have seen it
across my screen that's like the
beginning of the sentence and the end of
the sentence it wouldn't have been
across my screen right because my
husband and I both know what a real
marriage is right and we entered into it
very seriously that's why you take those
vows right you know and I meet and it
just there are so many different layers
to this that are very complicated and
Hung's of jokes what is apparent and
what's very sad about it is that it
represents that there are so many of us
who do not understand what matters
relationship is right and that's why
black women today are struggling to find
a black man who could hold space for
them and vice versa because we have
stuff like this happening like hunger
was really like I didn't know what I did
y'all with faithful try right hardy B
isn't because cardi would normally get
on IG live I was oh it's over over so in
other news Nicki Minaj is clapping back
at those who criticize her new boo for
being a convicted sex offender she
posted he was 15 she was 16 in a
relationship but go off internet y'all
can't run my life y'all can't even run
your own life I just you know Nicki has
put me through so much this year I know
I just got back that cute thing couldn't
get worse than q3 here we going q4 near
Dana a convicted rapist what did you
guys think about happen so fast right
she posted the picture didn't it's quick
what's the picture 17 most shots were
available within the hour I would like
them but then like I also feel like
Nicki has just been associated with a
lot of problematic men this year you
know I mean she's you know obviously she
can't decide who her brother is but
she's got a lot of blowback for the way
she's the kind of supported her brother
financially during his trial for a child
sex crime of some sort and 6:9 she put
him on a song and it went triple
platinum even though he was also pled
guilty to the same kind of charge in sex
with a child and then now she's begging
this man who had the same situation did
any of you guys have any strong feelings
about this you know what ray time again
how desensitized she can be to just our
fans just in general right a lot of
Barb's out there as well you say
anything wrong on Twitter or anywhere
about they gotta be tired
it won't go at this point they gotta be
on payrolls but you mean they will do
a bone or the retainer right and so that
that for me as a fan that's why I always
land I always say well but what about
the victims and what about those people
who call you their queen because that's
what a queen does in real life they say
listen I am going to respect you guys
and I'm going to have a listening ear
mm-hmm then I'm going to figure this out
in a way that's pleasing to you all now
I'm not saying that she should live for
us all right yeah don't be a mystery
there's nothing soft about it on the
other side of Nikki's life the Grammy
nominations were announced last week
okay and a handful of people think she
was snubbed but she's not the only
artist that was mentioned nuia Imani
tweeted Jay Cole's not in the Illuminati
that's the only reason I can come up
with for him not getting up any Grammy
nominee oh you guys think got snubbed
for the Grammys this year
do you guys did anybody think that Queen
should have gotten a nomination I
listened to it a few times it wasn't the
best I might have ever heard
Jay Cole really impacts me Maggie is
like right phenomena if that definitely
feels like Grammys what's up yeah I mean
part of me feels like and I know
Jermaine does not care he has a thousand
times he could care less about the
Grammys my only the only thing I'm
holding on to is that maybe he didn't
submit it even for the Grammys I'm
hoping that's the case no I think the
muse does just every year I think that
there's nothing wrong here
and we do the same thing with the
Grammys in the Oscars we say oh my god
they did it again every year there are
people who are very deserving of it who
don't even make an inability you
understand I mean so this is not a
surprise for me I'm dying I'll be tuned
into the n-double-a-cp Awards they
always get it right that's the value
that we put on the Grammys in all of
these why yes yes we want to put the
Grammys away up in all these other black
awards that are specifically celebrating
us yeah n double acp Awards yearly and
they always get it right I'm like viola
is like I got 19,000 n-double-a-cp
Awards why are you guys acknowledging my
greatness man I have a dissenting
opinion no I live for Jermaine right out
Fayetteville right I'll say John nah man
I I wouldn't hear for candy like no I
hate to bring these two same thing
opinion um I got it I own it I listen to
it I can appreciate certainly certain
songs on it it just wasn't my like
favorite that's saying okay but that
said comparatively speaking I wasn't
blown away with any of those Grammy
nominations in that category oh I
actually only I actually really liked
the album of the Year nominations for
the Grammys this year for hip-hop even
album of the year about the same I
regret all day like we one of my family
did
[Applause]
we have a lot of black people for album
of their shirt they might just give it
to the one white person who got
nominated more possible or god forbid
Jesus
Drake is nominated and Kendrick for
myzel win everything like literally if
you listen to the radio what's the same
song they're like okay that's the way
okay but see who else folks are
nominating for King status in preaching
or reaching the first tweet is from
haters who said this about LeBron James
greatest all-around player of all time
greatest leader of all time greatest
pastor of all time Graham's basketball
IQ of all time greatest scorer of all
time well okay Brad we get it you love
LeBron rondell is this sweet preaching
or reaching by Colin LeBron the goal of
all things basketball you know what
here's the thing it's a similar
conversation to the king of R&B there's
a lot of great people right like LeBron
is one of the greats all those all the
things that that we said are correct
because what no I'm saying I'm saying
I'm saying as one of but okay no there's
preachy or reaching that reaches before
you give us your reasoning is it a
preacher we've got pick one it's in
between but if I had to pick one I would
say preaching okay yeah because okay how
about you Jovian yo we're talking about
my favorite people all day
[Applause]
we're full of flexes today hey LeBron
see you in a minute I would be with
Jovian fancy preaching to reach a he's
he's preaching to an extent specifically
he's preaching on the act of service and
leadership like broad as a as a star
who's done so much for the game of
basketball in terms of like community
building the school everything else
preaching yeah period okay so the next
tweet is from comedian keV on stage who
cracks me up on a regular he said sister
add to is quite possibly the best sequel
ever much better than the original ray
is he preaching or reaching oh he is
preaching was another sister remembers
oh happy day actually is it on Netflix
because I'm dead serious
in resupplying nunnery backward and
almost made me want to be one because I
thought it was just like hey lik I get
just a million appreciative reaching
that is absolutely preaching yeah
everything was made up yeah he taught me
how
[Music]
[Applause]
okay Ally beat that says he Flavor of
Love was the best reality show of our
time endless laugh and foolery much
alike this show who wants to take this
one is it a preacher reach Rey yo no no
I can't remember her name but when she's
around and we're after and grabs a damn
listen it's a priest so words are free
this the names you name somebody Bucky
mm-hmm you know nickname those nicknames
will go down
do you remember Charm School yeah
Monique that never happened if it wasn't
for flavor love flavor love start a lot
of things oh and first of all anybody
kissing Flavor Flav on any level at any
time it's just the most entertaining but
not entertaining thing in the world and
so man right Jovi's it wasn't a preacher
reach I mean that's your favorite
reality show of all time it was not my
favorite Chauvelin reach it's a reach
okay finally it's time for my last word
[Music]
okay so if you follow me on twitter or
ra my close friend circle on instagram
you already know this is about to be
true about drake on vacation because
honey
Drake was giving me selfies with the
beard off thick and juicy
in the skin all clear giving me a squint
light you really think you've done with
me since cuz you not sure I am still
fine on vacation then he was giving me
ABS and his random array of tattoos and
the whole shower showing us how big it
is and all the things you've been doing
there on the gram on the Instagram and I
might drink like are you trying to I
can't
hell if I never want this vacation to
end or if I needed to end immediately
from my help because the fact is really
I'm ashamed of myself
honestly like yeah I'm really ashamed
but I thought I was past it and then I
was like oh I'm not and I don't know
this because Drake just Keith doesn't do
this often like he doesn't flex like
before it's a story off day he only
doesn't every now and then that's the
way I got out was that brunch and just
face popped up on my screen oh my God
he's just I'm trying to give white skin
men up in 29 days
I can't the devil is the lights a good
man with a beard and a lot of rap hits
don't let him get you sis champagne
puffy don't never stop my alerts are on
that's all I got I'm so but thirst aside
thank you all for joining up just a week
I'm Sylvia o bell I'll see you right
here next Wednesday at 9:00 p.m. Eastern
for a hello opinion see ya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]